I'm from the forest yeah got that going
for me
I drop in northern Wisconsin and all the
women look like me there you know like
Oh curvy boy yeah it's an androgynous
utopia up there
I'm just I'm used to scrappy women you
know in school my lunch ladies growing
up their names were bunny cookie and
candy yes because it was God's as soon
as you get done being a stripper yeah
you'll get it rolled into the lunch lady
protection program you want you wanted
more mac and cheese man I'll put it into
your lap for a dollar
[Applause]
what's so thick wasn't it they always
served you a hot starch in school to see
if you could learn an adverse condition
you can't it can't what time I asked a
gal in the front row here in LA I said
you guys comfort food and she goes yeah
salads yes what oh you can't even wipe a
tear with a piece of salad you can't do
it it's too wet guys it's too much you
need a Tater Tot
that's why tater tots were invented
there's like little sponges that absorb
your emotions
tater tots
care about you yeah
not salad salad is cold and unconcerned
with your problems
lettuce wants you to cry so you can grow
more lettuce that's the slogan of
lettuce mark tears please I this is
where you guys sit wow so much closer
than before
I I love mashed potatoes that's what I
need right you're you and me oh my gosh
I need a man-sized mound of mashed
potatoes for the hard times that I can
just burrow into it
yep burrow in there and you make a
feelings cave and you turn on some NPR
and you wait for turkey roaster come on
and you wait in there until you feel
better or until this presidency is over
[Applause]
you guys are nice I was in the DMV the
other day and I met a 98 year old man in
there yeah
98 guys Wow why didn't why does he still
have to go really can't maybe when
you're like 88 can't they be like uh
here you go sir here's your forever
license you've been here so much but he
was doing paperwork with his great
granddaughters and he he goes he goes
girls girls don't you mark me dawn as a
donor Wow 98 yeah who draws the short
straw on that a free
good news-bad we found your bad news you
got two months to left
hmm we through the paperwork and and the
girls say grandpa you can't check the
donor box because you already donated
your body to the University of Minnesota
yeah that guy would check the box
he would've double-booked this organ he
can't even retire when he's dad he's
busy busy busy MIT this one lady holy
cow
she she's telling me all about her heart
surgery up north that my sister's bar
over booze and cigarettes
yeah cuz Eve is not a quitter yeah turns
out she had a heart transplant yes but
it wasn't a human heart in there wasn't
human heart you was a pig hurt you hear
this sighs yeah oh yeah yeah it's a real
thing only problem is you got to wait
till a pig dies in a car accident
you